après 16 modes enquête de la gendarmerie
le dossier chance demain c'est désormais
la police judiciaire de dijon qui mène
les investigations
une des pistes possibles c'est une c'est
un personne qui aurait commis des faits
à proximité de la famille or on sait
aussi qu'un membre de la famille et dans
la gendarmerie et donc pour éviter toute
polémique
le juge d'instruction avec l'accord du
procureur de la république
enfin avec en tout cas la probation pour
un procure la public a souhaité confier
l'enquêté à la pj pour éviter toute
polémique depuis des mois l'instituteur
un temps mise en examen dénonçait cette
situation si des paroles de l'enfant qui
désignait le maître comme son agresseur
ont amené hérité clay à faire de la
prison les traces de sperme et l'adn
d'un membre de la famille de la victime
découvert sur sa culotte n'ont pas
entraîné de poursuites il ya un effet
d'annonce qui évidemment me plais bien
parce que j'ai vraiment la sensation que
les choses vont pouvoir bouger
il ya eu deux temps dans cette enquête
une enquête sur moi qui a été donc à
charge complètement et donc une piste
écarter totalement qui est celle de la
famille on peut se dire que si ça avait
été la police judiciaire dès le départ
ce n'est pas une piste corps est écarté
deux semaines après avoir dénoncé une
inertie de la justice l'association
innocence en danger voit cette décision
comme un tournant
maintenant il y à un procureur et public
qui me semble enfin je n'ai donc plus
seul dans ce dossier
aujourd'hui la mise en examen il faut
qu'elle intervienne rapidement il ya des
éléments graves et concordants dans ceux
de chez vous remettre en cause et en
examen en proche de cette petite fille
des résultats de nouvelles expertises
scientifiques et informatiques sont
attendus dans les prochains jours aux
enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
maintenant de les exploiter au mieux
pour faire toute la lumière sur cette
affaire